hello and welcome to this video playing
blossomed blue velvet okay
blue velvet is playing the Scotch I
don't remember I think we need seven is
right and then there is a d6 + f6 even
f6 as possible
and it's been a while since I studied
this I think Bishop c7 does not work due
to d6 yeah okay now just these six I
guess white stone needs to recover that
d4 pawn
I always got no interest in doing that
okay and I'm just a pawn up for some
compensation white has some compensation
okay he probably has 95 on the when the
agenda do I have to go h6 night h4 then
is is an idea yeah but okay I have to
probably prevent 95
okay now 96 is this idea
if it takes on h8 stuff to trap the noid
you can me I can go d5 here and it goes
96 and maybe this is actually an idea
and then rook to H 7 yeah that could
work
I've got a tempo on the bishop now and
the Bishop f5 next yeah that should be
fine
[Music]
hmm I was a bit surprised that there was
a pause at all it looked completely
forced to take on his heaven yeah I
wonder if white still has some
compensation or if it is dwindling down
enough now it definitely is dwindling a
bit but I came probably no big choice oh
that was a Muslim I wanted to go King g7
of course and it seems to be not yeah
it's not not such awful
who Ruki aid is actually quite a decent
idea making this 7 had the same idea of
course but yeah it's not not a problem
this small slip
yeah this is opposite color to bishops
but maybe maybe I can do some things my
king is a bit more active my is he's
helping me helping me a bit even a3
comes into consideration here
I mean many many moves are better for me
some okay
this bishop is really quite seriously
misplaced
I would probably get two connected pawns
because he has to take on a four at some
point maybe even here
I could have played c4 even
this is fine
Misha 1 g3 is amazingly bad okay now um
the C pawn will start running
okay yeah this opening line I think is
totally unpromising for white um
if white wants to do anything here I
think um I think you should try to
Castle if I'm not mistaken this this
already is pretty much nothing f6 and d6
both is good this is also completely
fine white has to get into something
something like this I believe and this
is just nothing at all an f6 dots across
so I had this he cannot take now after
the six that is trapped you can okay you
can secure it
you don't losing it should be five but
it's not a good line and here really AM
there is not much going on black it's
just fine
maybe Bishop c5 iam but okay he went
here and it is a bit of compensation
probably a sixer as the engine points
out is inaccurate if you go here and
castlelong next set should be fine
I'm not certain about the game here it
was a little bit dangerous age six and
now it went he went Knight age form yeah
this is this is working but it's kind of
it's not extremely high Mon yes Bishop
g3 turned out to be mistake at the
pieces just not play well play say at
all should probably go here or something
here I think here I'm really just upon
up for not much at all
my coordination is good and it's just
not there's nothing really good going on
I wanted to go King D 7 at King f8 was a
Mouse Club but fortunately it did not
spoil all that much and the ending is
not fun provider it's it's a pawn I have
the better production it sounds a bit
audio that does you say have the better
structure but I really have now it's
it's just it's easier to take this and
what this should be 6a v 2 PA and those
pawns are just very safe and he's got
the most problem and most important part
of this is the terrible Bishop down one
thing I could have done I could have
played c4 you immediately that would
have been interesting as well but I mean
I just kept complete control and from
yeah it's just very simple very simple
win ok guys thanks for watching